- [Interviewer] How does
voter turnout in midterms
compare to presidential elections?
- Traditionally, midterm
elections have been years
in which the voter turnout is much lower
than a presidential
election, and particularly
in recent history where the
American political scene
has been really dominated
by the president.
We can start that really
with John F. Kennedy,
when he became a celebrity president
and really everybody increasingly
has just sort of seen
American political activity
originating and swirling
around a president.
And so if they're
interested in the president,
well, they turn out for
the presidential election.
But in the off-year
elections, in the midterms,
well, the president's
not really on the ballot
even if some people tend
to see the elections
as a referendum on his presidency.
So people turn out in lower numbers.
We've also seen a trend, and
it may be upturned in 2018,
but a trend where Republican
voters, who tend to be older,
participate in the voting
in midterm elections more
than younger voters, who
tend to vote Democratic,
or voters of color, who vote
for the Democratic Party as well.
That's always been one of
the challenges for Democrats,
to get their team to turn out
and vote in these midterm elections.